[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I'm thrilled to
introduce JP Joffrey Hard Tango
Chamber Band, with a special
guest, Lara St. John,
playing violin.
[APPLAUSE]
Please welcome
and here they are.
JP JOFRE: Hello.
Well, hello everyone.
Thank you so much
for being here.
We're very excited to be
sharing some new music with you.
We are very used to play
this music at night.
So it's a little
bit hard for us.
But we are glad that it
looks a little bit dark now.
And, anyways, we're going
to start with a piece that
is called "After the
Curtains," written
for violin and bandoneon,
followed by "Universe."
So thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - JP JOFRE HARD
TANGO CHAMBER BAND,
"AFTER THE CURTAINS"]
[MUSIC - JP JOFRE HARD TANGO
CHAMBER BAND, "UNIVERSAL"]
[APPLAUSE]
Well, thank you so much.
The next piece we want to
play is called "Taranguino."
And it's a composition I wrote,
inspired by my grandfather, who
was an accordion player.
And he always wanted to play
the bandoneon, the instrument
I'm holding right now.
And it's a very
particular instrument
because every button plays
two notes, one note when
I open the bellows.
And the same button, when
I close, change the pitch.
And the interval is
always different.
And in this hand, I
have the lower register.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You have a C opening.
And when I close,
it becomes an F.
And the interval is
always different again.
So we have to practice
four keyboards, two
keyboards opening and
two keywords closing.
And so that's why my grandfather
choose the accordion.
[LAUGHTER]
And so I wrote
this piece for him.
It's called "Taranguino."
[MUSIC - JP JOFRE HARD TANGO
CHAMBER BAND, "TARANGUINO"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
The next piece we
want to perform
is called "After the Rain."
And I wrote this piece.
And it's about my father.
As you can tell,
I guess a little,
I get a lot of inspiration
from my family.
And so this is the
piece that I do here,
which means "After the Rain."
[MUSIC - JP JOFRE HARD TANGO
CHAMBER BAND, "AFTER THE RAIN"]
[APPLAUSE]
Chris Johnson on
the double bass.
So the next piece want to play
is one of my first composition.
And it's a piece I
wrote in Argentina,
in a very particular time.
It was 2001, '02, when we
had a huge economic crisis.
I remember we had five
presidents in one week, really.
At that time I decided I
wanted to be a bandoneon
player and a composer.
And I remember my
family was very upset.
They tell me, why you're not
a lawyer, or an architect,
or something else?
But when I told my
mother, she told me
she was very happy because
I was doing what I loved.
So I wrote this piece.
And the first movement is
inspired about my country.
The second movement is
inspired by my mother.
And I always say-- well, my
mom, she lives in Argentina now.
I say this because
every time we play
the piece, people come to me
and say, I'm sorry for your mom.
And she lives in
San Juan, Argentina.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you.
And this is "Tango Movement."
[MUSIC - JP JOFRE HARD TANGO
CHAMBER BAND, "TANGO MOVEMENT"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.
I'd like to introduce a
great pianist from Argentina,
who also produced our last CD,
Pablo Cafici; from the cello,
Amy Kang.
[APPLAUSE]
We are very proud tonight to
have as a special guest, Lara
St. John.
And once again, on the
double bass, Chris Johnson.
So we're heading to the end now.
We're going to play a
lullaby I wrote to my niece.
It's called "Duces Suenos,"
which means Sweet Dreams.
[MUSIC - JP JOFRE HARD TANGO
CHAMBER BAND, "DUCES SUENOS"]
[APPLAUSE]
Line Haddad and Diego Blanco.
Well, this is the last piece
we want to perform now.
Before that, we
want to thank you
all for coming this morning.
I'm used to saying tonight.
And we're very, very
glad to be here.
Thanks Google for inviting us.
This is a great, great
opportunity for us.
We're going to say goodbye
with a piece I had the pleasure
to record with Paquito
D'Rivera a few years ago.
And now Lara is going to
play the clarinet part.
This is "Primavera,"
which means Spring.
So thank you so much.
[MUSIC - JP JOFRE HARD TANGO
CHAMBER BAND, "PRIMAVERA"]
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Bravo.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
Thank you so much for
what you did here.
We have two microphones
open for questions.
We have a few minutes.
Can I ask you a question?
So as a composer
and a performer,
what is it like to perform
your own compositions?
JP JOFRE: Well, I always feel
like composing and performing
goes together.
And I feel like if I'm just
playing someone else's music,
I feel like I'm a
little bit empty.
And if my music is
performed by someone else,
I also feel a little bit empty.
So I feel like
composing and performing
is the right balance for me,
in my personal experience.
Sometimes in the beginning,
when I first moved to New York,
it was a little bit
complicated to start
presenting my own music.
I had to learn the traditional
repertoire for tango,
for the music of Piazzolla.
Little by little, I
started playing my music.
And then people started to ask
me to play more of my music
at some point.
And some presenters asked me
to, no, just perform your music.
Now, today-- well, for
the past two years,
I've been mostly only
just playing my music.
I'm very, very happy for that.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: And tango is such a
big part of everybody's life
here.
I just want to ask what is
tango for you, and for whoever
wants to answer the question?
JP JOFRE: Diego?
[LAUGHTER]
DIEGO BLANCO: Well, tango,
it took a lot of stages.
I mean that's tango
for a long time.
And first, it was fun.
And then it became a passion.
Today, is more like a companion,
and a passion, and my future.
So it depends.
It really takes on many shapes.
Tango is so practiced.
You learn a lot about
yourself through tango,
through practicing.
I'm sure through
the music as well.
I haven't played
an instrument yet.
So I don't know.
But through the
body, definitely it
teaches you a lot
about yourself.
So it's everything, I think.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS JOHNSON: OK.
Hello?
Yeah.
I thought originally,
I guess as a child,
I thought tango is like a dance.
I've seen couples with
a rose in their mouth.
And as I got older
and got a chance
to play some of the music, I
got to play a lot of Piazzola,
realize how great it was.
And then I ran into JP a couple
years ago, about 10 years-- not
even 10 years, seven ago, maybe?
JP JOFRE: Yeah.
CHRIS JOHNSON: And then we
started playing together.
And, like, it's been a great
ride so far and so good.
So can't complain.
LARA ST. JOHN: I guess for
me, I did the 25th anniversary
of Astor Piazzolla's
Central Park concert
about five years ago in Central
Park, at the same bandshell,
and actually with the same
pianist, with Pablo Ziegler.
So that's kind of what started
me and my sort of tango stuff.
We've gone on the road quite
a bit doing that program
and other programs
with-- well, not with JP,
but another bando player.
But a lot of the
rhythms are the same
as what he puts into his music.
And I mean, you must have
been really heavily influenced
by Piazzolla's stuff--
JP JOFRE: Yeah.
LARA ST. JOHN:
--in certain ways.
JP JOFRE: I grew up
listening to Piazzolla.
I grew up with my grandmother.
And she used to listen to
tango from 8:00 AM to 11:00 PM
every day.
LARA ST. JOHN: You know,
funny enough, so did my dad.
Weird for a Canadian.
[LAUGHTER]
JP JOFRE: I have two now.
AUDIENCE: So, well, thanks
for the performance.
Loved you music.
Maybe there's a good
story here or not.
But I was somewhat
excited, trying to find
where can I find a
bandoneon to buy?
And the music stores were all,
like, oh, no, no, you just
find them.
I don't know.
It's kind of mysterious.
But where do you
find a bandoneon?
JP JOFRE: That's a question.
[LAUGHTER]
That's a good question.
Before I play bandoneon,
I was a drummer.
And I remember, I was
walking the streets.
And I saw a bandoneon
in a music store.
And it was the only
instrument in the store.
It was a very old bandoneon.
So I exchanged the drum
set for the bandoneon.
And I remember the store
guy, he was very happy
because at the time nobody
wanted to buy a bandoneon.
Now, it's very difficult to
find bandoneons in Argentina
because most of them,
they are taken to Japan.
In Japan, there are a
lot of bandoneon players.
And in Europe, there are a lot
of bandoneon players as well.
So there was a time that it was
very cheap to buy in Argentina.
So most bandoneons were gone.
But in those days, there
are many factories.
There is a factory in Germany.
The most famous one is
Double A, Alfred Arnold.
And this is actually
a bandoneon from them,
that they gave to
me as a sponsorship.
And in Argentina, there
is another, Lucia,
doing bandoneons now.
He's really good.
So in those days, if you
want to buy a bandoneon,
it's more easier than before,
than 10 years ago, for example.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it true that,
like, the greatest bandoneons
were actually made in Germany?
JP JOFRE: Yeah.
The instrument was
invented in Germany.
And it was invented to play
religious music at the church.
And somehow, it ended up in
the cabarets in Argentina.
And it became the main
voice of tango music.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And that's it.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Where can we listen
to you in New York?
Do you play live anywhere?
Do you play at any milongas?
JP JOFRE: Yeah.
We actually have on Sunday,
we have in concert in Mezzrow.
Actually, Amy can say.
AMY KANG: Yeah.
So we play different
places, like concert halls
and like jazz clubs.
This Sunday we'll be playing
at a jazz club called
Mezzrow in the West Village.
It's on West 10th Street.
It's like a little
basement space.
But it's beautiful,
intimate, and kind of
like the perfect
setting for this music.
JP JOFRE: After that?
AMY KANG: Sunday
evening, 8:00 o'clock.
JP JOFRE: Great.
And after that,
we're going to Korea
to perform in a new hall, Lotte
Hall in Seoul, and in Japan.
Well, if you want
to know more dates,
our website is jpjofre.com/hard
tangochamberband.
There you can find more
information about us.
AUDIENCE: And what's your
synergy with the dancing?
You didn't mention you're
playing at any milongas.
So that's why I asked that.
JP JOFRE: Well, when
I moved to New York,
I started working
a lot of milongas.
My dream was always to play a
concert, like a concert set up.
And so that's kind of following
the Piazzolla tradition.
So I'm not at the moment playing
in milongas or with that.
And this is special case
where Line Haddad and Diego
Blanco are amazing dancers.
And we're very happy to do it.
But mostly, like they
say, 95% of the time,
we are doing like concerts
like the way we just did.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JP JOFRE: You're welcome.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
JP JOFRE: OK.
[APPLAUSE]